this is a Friday edition of the PFT p.m.
podcast kind of and sort of it it's PFT
p.m. it's PFT ot I guess ot special
circumstances have arisen because
moments after I taped the PFT p.m.
podcast for Friday Antonio Brown was
released by the New England Patriots so
before we get to the PFT p.m. podcast a
little extra to get you up to speed on
what happened this afternoon and where
it all heads from here so the news is
this Antonio Brown tweeted just after
4:00 p.m. Eastern what seemed to be a
farewell to the New England Patriots
thanks for the opportunity appreciate at
Patriots was the tweet I quickly
confirmed that indeed Antonio Brown has
been released by the Patriots the
Patriots have since issued this
statement the New England Patriots are
releasing Antonio Brown we appreciate
the hard work of many people over the
past 11 days but we feel that it is best
to move in a different direction at this
time that's it they don't get into any
of the specifics the whys and the
wherefores and they weren't gonna cut
him based solely upon the civil lawsuit
that was filed one day after Antonio
Brown joined the team last Monday they
thought it would be a horrible precedent
as it would be to fire someone based
simply upon uncorroborated allegations
contained in a civil complaint but in
the 10 days since the lawsuit was filed
other things have happened things we
know about and things we don't know
about we know about the 10-hour meeting
between the NFL and Britney Taylor the
woman who sued Antonio Brown last week
in 10 hours some information undoubtedly
was gathered and maybe it was credible
maybe it was passed along to the
Patriots maybe the Patriots conducted
their own shadow
background investigation to get more
information I know I would if it was up
to me if it's my team I'm not just gonna
sit and wait I have resources available
I want to find out are these claims
false or are they accurate I want to
know more before I continue to allow
this relationship to go forward because
if it goes forward and it shouldn't it
does damage to my reputation to my team
to my brand and then you throw on top of
it
what
and on Thursday night the story that
broke from si.com the second accuser who
emerged on Monday with an incident that
wasn't nearly as egregious as the things
that were contained in the civil
complaint but still bad enough to
trigger scrutiny of Antonio Brown and
potentially bad enough to get him sued
again or under separate scrutiny the
league office he intimidated he harassed
he retaliated against that second
accuser via a group text message that
amazingly included his own lawyer so to
the extent that this was building with
things that maybe we know about and
maybe we don't the one thing that
everyone found out about Thursday night
quite possibly was the straw that broke
the camel's back and for the patriot
that's a fairly big deal because they
gave him a 9 million dollar signing
bonus they've paid one installment the
other installment hasn't been paid yet
but but they may try to not pay him
that amount and they may try to get some
of that money back it all depends upon
the language of the contract and the
language of the CBA usually though with
a signing bonus
it takes a suspension it takes a
retirement it takes something
significant by the player to allow the
team to get any of it back whether it's
the amount that's been paid or the
amount that hasn't been paid but you
know what the Patriots could choose to
just refuse to pay the second
installment and for San Antonio Brown to
fight for it because maybe along the way
the Patriots will get lucky and they'll
get some sort of a ruling that favors
them and allows them to keep that money
now whatever he keeps coming out of his
time in New England Antonio Brown
becomes a free agent he's free to sign
with any other team just like he was
only 13 days ago and yes can you believe
it it's only been 13 days since he was
cut by the Oakland Raiders free agent
free to sign I'm assuming it shows up on
the transaction report for Friday which
means he's available right now to come
to terms with another team and sign a
contract as soon as tonight it would
become official tomorrow who will pursue
him now when you consider that Bill
Belichick so quickly went after Antonio
Brown despite everything that we knew
about without hesitation
Bill Belichick pursued Antonio Brown and
it led to speculation that maybe maybe
Antonio Brown
acted a certain way to get out of
Oakland the same way he acted a certain
way to get out of Pittsburgh and maybe
this was an inside job and of course
it's all irrelevant now but the fact
that Bill Belichick was ready to give
this guy safe harbor it's gonna make
another team all it takes is one I see
this all the time
31 teams can shout he'll know about the
prospect of signing a player if one team
whispers yes it's all it takes
Washington they were interested in
trading for tyree kill I was told
earlier this offseason back during
training camp when Trent Williams was
and still is holding out and there was
some thought that maybe they could work
something out and end up with Tyree kill
when I didn't get a Antonio Brown and do
you look that look look what Washington
did last year with Rubin Foster is what
they did with Rubin Foster worse than
what they may do with Antonio Brown
Rubin fostered it had been arrested
Rubin Foster was facing criminal charges
and it all worked out for Washington I
could see Washington saying hey you've
already made nine million for this year
how about we sign you to a one-year six
million dollar contract and off we go so
that's the first team just because
dysfunctional teams do dysfunctional
things and currently there's no PR
director in Washington because Tony
Wiley has left for the Special Olympics
I don't know that there's a voice of
reason right now to talk Bruce Allen and
Dan Snyder out of being seduced by the
talent that Antonio Brown clearly has so
no matter what anyone else does with
Antonio Brown whether they sign and
whether they don't sign the lead still
has an investigation that is not going
anywhere
the league has the prerogative and the
obligation to continue to investigate
and the the lawyers for the second
accuser issued a statement not long
before Antonio Brown was cut by the
Patriots indicating that the league has
made it clear that Brown was told do not
have any further communication with this
individual in the mere fact that the
league would be responsible for issuing
that mandate tells you the league thinks
it's problematic that Antonio Brown did
that so between the first accuser the
second accuser the allegation of
intimidation of the second accuser
Antonio Brown is looking at an eventual
suspension quite possibly
if you're Washington you say alright how
long is he gonna be suspended we'll take
him on we'll pay him as he goes if he
gets suspended we don't pay him if he
gets put on the commissioner example
let's see that's the problem
they paid Reuben foster last year on the
commissioner exempt list but they
weren't paying him very much
whoever takes him on now is undertaking
the risk that Antonio Brown will end up
on the commissioner exempt list and
they'll have to pay him so I'd want to
be damn sure whether or not he's going
to be on the commissioner exempt list
before I sign Antonio Brown so it's a
complicated situation and the league
still has jurisdiction even though he's
not currently employed and any other
team out there can sign him can take a
flier if they want to maybe it's a one
year minimum deal at this point for
Antonio Brown the bottom line is this
whether he intentionally wanted out of
Pittsburgh or Oakland or not he now
unintentionally has been ejected by the
New England Patriots and it feels like
it's going to be a while before anyone
is interested in hiring Antonio Brown
again if ever that's it for this extra
little addition of PFT pmpf t ot ot
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports